We're going to be talking about
Kiro powers. So I'm doing the He-Man
power
move so similar for you. How many of you,
quick, quick show of your hands, how many people here have used
hero? All
right, cool, um,
handful.
How many people have heard of Quiro?
Yeah, I think we did our job, uh, when I, I,
I had a session day one
and I asked the audience and it was like 30%
and like by day 4 now it's, uh,
everyone knows about Kiro,
so we're hoping that, you know, we, a lot more
of you try Quiro over
like once you get back to,
uh, over the holidays actually
and hope all of you took advantage of the 1000
free credits you can get
at the
uh Kiro haunted house
back at the Venetian.
So today we're going to talk about powers. This is a feature
that we launched just yesterday morning.
I will get into what it is and and what
problem it solves, but here's the rough agenda. We'll
start with
the general problem that we were trying to solve
with powers.
How we're going about solving it.
And then I will,
I'll do a live demo, so hopefully the demo gods
are with me. Uh,
and, oh, I, I totally forgot. I forgot to introduce,
uh, we, we have two partners here. I have
Harry Mauer, who's the CTO of Postman,
and then, uh, Tyler Schuckert,
who's a Devre engineer at Superbase,
and they're gonna talk about,
uh, their use cases about how they're using
powers to really streamline the
onboarding for,
uh, API development and backend
development. Now
I'm sure you've seen a variant of the slide
over the last 4 days over 1000 times.
Uh, AI has transformed software dev. Uh,
what started with inline code
suggestions that would give you a function
has now evolved to full blown agents
that are able to.
Build large features in your code base.
But one of the problems is that AI
agents are still generalists.
Jack of all trades, if you will.
So every time you go to do something specific
like you're, you're working on a front end
or you're working on an API
or a back end,
there's a lot of massaging you have to do with the,
with the agent,
providing the agent a lot of context.
To get the right outcome you want.
For specialized tasks, agents do
face challenges. The first one really.
Is that
Software is evolving every day. Every day
there's a new SDK.
Every day there's like a new, new tool
or technology that's launched.
The models that power the agents are often
trained on data that isn't
up to date.
So,
if you want to work with an SDK like the strands
TypeScript SDK for agent development came
out at reinvent.
You're gonna have to figure out how to get the model to,
or the agent to build strand
stuff. You could link it to the docks,
but it's just gonna go ahead and
Decide what it wants to do.
And the second problem is that even when the agent
does,
uh, know about or even when the agent does
know about a particular piece of technology or a
framework.
It can miss steps and it can, it can
not follow, it doesn't really have an onboarding manual
for that, uh,
for that for a technology.
MCP was built to solve that problem. How many
of you are familiar with MCP?
OK, so MCP is a model context
provider. It was a, it's a, it's a convention that
was built
so that you could share, so it allowed for
agents an extensible model when working
with agents.
So for example, both our partners here today, Postman
and Superbase, have MCP servers.
The MCP servers really talk to their APIs,
so they're able to do things like list projects,
update tables, create collections.
Um,
but the MCP alone, um, is
also
not enough. The, the problem that happens
with agents is as you add more and more agent
MCPs to your agent.
The agent gets overwhelmed with con with
context.
And a real problem that's emerged in the industry as a
whole is context rot that as more tools
get added and and are made
available to the agent.
Performance degrades, so and quality output
declines.
Additionally, with the even with the MCP
server in hand.
There's often guidance and onboarding instructions
that are completely missed that the agent
just does not follow.
So what you often need to pair is almost a combination
of MCP.
And context
Now a lot of solutions have popped up even
beyond MCP in the market now. You have,
uh, cloud Skills, you know, they recently launched
anthropically recently launched,
it's called Tool Search Tool, kind of a weird name,
um, that, that allows you to like dynamically
discover tools.
Uh, you have cursor rules, you have agents.
MD, but they're sub-agents.
But they're all different ways
to
get to the same thing and
just if you go look online in the
forums and on Reddit,
people are very confused, like, what do I use,
when do I use, what,
like, and there's a, there are tons of
YouTube videos about
MCP versus skills versus sub-agents,
and they all kind of do
the, the, the end goal is really you want
to generate code
for your to match your intent.
And so we really took a step back with
with powers and we
thought about how do we one.
Get the agent to learn
something specialized.
And 2,
do it in a way where it doesn't actually
overwhelm the agent with context.
And that's kind of why we launched Hero Powers.
So what hero powers do
is that they give they're a
bundle that is a that give the agent
extensible specialized capabilities,
right? So it really makes your hero agent extensible
so you can add a power,
uh, and then the agent knows about that power.
And when you, you do it, you take on a task
that is related to the power,
the agent can just automatically discover it.
The unique thing here is that as you
add these powers.
They're not just, ah,
they're not going to overwhelm your agent with context,
because the agent is getting very minimal
information. About
the specific
technology. So in this case if we add Postman
and Figma
sorry, Postman and Superbase,
the agent just knows about that that it
has these postman capabilities available
and if you ask questions about APIs,
it'll automatically just say hey I need to use the
Postman power
and they'll actually start going ahead and um
following the instructions in the power.
What the power really contains, and I'll show this in the demo,
is a combination of it has,
it's a front matter, it's got front matter and markdown,
so there's a power. MD file
that defines basically onboarding instructions
and a workflow
for the agent to follow, and that's
the that's the only required
piece of information.
But what you can also do is, is combine that
with MCP tools to really make it powerful.
So power is the is the only available
solution out there right now that combines
steering and MCP
in one bucket
and what we do is we have a we
have a template really for the Power
MD
that allows you to do things on install
uh and on activation.
Allow you to install hooks
and ah steering files, which we'll,
I'll I'll kind of show you in the demo.
We've partnered with um
partners, so we've got a curated set of partners.
Yeah, we've, we've, uh, partnered with partners across
the life cycle of application development.
So from UI development with Figma
to API development with Postman
to backend development with Superbase and Neon
to payments with Stripe.
And
It's not just curated powers we've built it in
a way so anyone can build a power.
So in fact, in my demo what I'm gonna
do today is start with one of the curate powers and then
actually like live build a power
and and bring it into my project.
What that allows is really the community to build
a whole variety of powers. Just yesterday
at my last session I had 3,
individuals come up to me and say, Hey,
I've got this really cool use case for a power.
They, they were
doing Java upgrades and
apparently that's really hard. I'm not a Java developer,
um, and.
Uh,
we already have, there's like multiple
repos. Someone created a Kiro Powers repo
overnight,
and they've got like a playwright power, right?
So it's really
gonna open up an extensible model of working
with Quiro.
Cause I trust me you're gonna have a power for that.
And what we've done is we've, our UX
is also
uh very simple.
So within the Quiro interface, so Kiro,
the ID interface,
we have a new power spane.
Where you just click on the power.
It loads our curated powers, and you can
just one click install it.
And you will, you see this very shortly.
And as I called out, even from the same interface,
you can build your own power
or import a power.
So if you got a public GitHub URL, someone
on the Internet shared this power being like, hey, this is
a super cool
playwright power I built,
you can just add that and your agent will have
awareness of that.
The 2nd use case is a start of
phase 1 of our journey towards more governance
for teams around powers.
Uh, but it'll enable
it alone will already enable teams. So let's say you
have a team and you want, you define,
you know, coding,
coding conventions, you define
rules around how you work with, uh, particular
technology. You can define that in a repository
with powers, and you can
actually import the power from a folder
so each developer can clone the repository
to their individual environments and actually import powers.
We're going to make that a lot better in the future.
And finally, this, this kind of organically
came up as we were working with partners
because every partner was saying, hey, like now I've
got to maintain like these
unique files for every for every
provider
because as, as we all know, there's a lot of
agentic tools out there.
And uh what we wanted
to do was not build something that's proprietary
in nature so hopefully
once we've with the way we built this under the hood
is that
uh powers is is itself an MCP
server. So
hopefully once we make this public, we didn't make
this public, uh, immediately, but you
can use powers with,
you know, Klein,
the hero CLI
cursor,
maybe even clot code.
And hopefully when we, once we do that,
um, you know.
Harry and Tyler here will be able to keep that one
file and actually
if when working with multiple providers
they can just provide
that bundle as context.
And so I think I've
spoken enough about powers here. So let me
actually go ahead
and
switch to a live demo.
Since there were many people in the audience
who have not actually used Quiro.
Let me give you a quick,
quick tour of the interface. So Quiro
is an ID fork of code OSS,
and what we really have, uh, is this, so
this Kiropane here.
Has
features that we launched with,
so the application that I'm showing you today is an
application I've built in my last 2 demos. It's a job seeker's
app. So, uh, the,
the pitch here and, uh, and my,
my plan is after this I'm gonna
quit, quit my job and go build, build the next
billion dollar unicorn
is, uh,
the, the, but the pitch here is that.
People looking for jobs often like
there's tools and there's enough information
available to practice questions, but there isn't
really a way to practice, uh,
like tone and style and how and diction
and how you're answering something
so we built, we live built this
app in a one hour session
where essentially the flow is like.
A user starts an interview. You voice record
the answer.
We transcripted the answer,
and then after you go through the interview,
we send the results to an, uh,
an AI SD cloud SDK
that then
generates a qualitative and quantitative
score
of your, of how you did.
And we use specs, uh, so if you're not
attended any of the sessions on Quiro,
Specs is the, the unique
feature that we added to the space. It gives a
structured approach to building
with AI because you can really plan
effectively before you go and implement work.
So, to give you a, can everyone see the interface
OK? I can, um, I'll just make it a little bigger.
Sorry. To
give you an overview of the interface, so you start with
a prompt, and what we break that prompt into
user stories and acceptance criteria that actually
define like your requirements.
Um, so in this case you see things like as a job
interview, as a job seeker I wanna answer interview
questions using voice recording
so that I can practice speaking.
Then we, we switched to a design
and the design really like if you look at it, it starts with an architecture
diagram, so this is a this is a React application
and it's got all the components and interfaces
within it. And then you get
to a task list, and the task list includes
optional, like optional tasks and required tasks
that you then you can then execute.
Now this entire flow we did this flow in a in a whole
session where we built this application
and uh I'll do a quick
demo of the application as well
because you can start with an interview.
And Agentic
development. Involves
working with MCPs
context
and tools.
Uh, it's, it's a hard problem to
solve, which is why we launched Powers.
Powers was it uh
Powers was a technical problem we solved recently.
Uh, we did this in a way where we,
we used the concept of progressive disclosure,
uh, to make
the agent effective.
I research things on the Internet
and using
social media.
And then what what this app does is that it then
sends this data over transcript transcribes
that data and sends it over
the web, the web
to, uh, cloud to the to an to
a model. The model analyzes the results
and gives me a score.
Uh, looks like I, I'm
not ready to get my,
get, get a job.
It's a lot of work I gotta do.
Uh, and, and gives you qualitative feedback as
well. Cool.
So that was a quick tour of the application.
I, I didn't really talk about the other
features, but we have hooks.
Hooks are a way, hooks are life cycle events,
so they actually like watch the IDE
for different events like file save, file
create, uh, we're adding more like
on agent com chat complete.
And you can actually do things, uh, you can
do actions so you can ask the agent to do
something
or you can run commands
it's kind of uh an enforcer if you will,
when you're working with agents.
And then as we talked about MCP and steering
are like ways to guide the agent to give the agent
rules to follow
when they when they build things.
It's a very quick overview of just the core
hero interface.
Um Now, what
we launched with Powers is this
new tab here.
So adding a power here is really easy. So what,
what I'm gonna do in this demo
is that I have this interface
here that I've built this, this was the interface
I built just in the, in my last session.
But I also have a Figma file that, let's
say my designer built,
and this is, this, this kind of looks much nicer
than what you just saw,
right? So what I'm gonna do is I'm, I'm
gonna try and get
Hiro to take this to,
I'm gonna install the Figma power
and try and have Quiro to go and implement this.
So let's actually go ahead and
install the Figma power.
All right, um, so that that was installed and
if you want to take a look at what a power looks like.
The power itself is just it's a
markdown file with the power. MD.
Let me open the front matter because it's the markdown
version because it's easier to
understand. So this is what
front matter looks like,
right? And you, as you can see, we have keywords related
to Figma like UI design, code,
layout,
uh, that help the agent
decipher when it should actually invoke
this power.
And with this power there's like a workflow defined, you
know, execute this file to generate the right context
for Figma
and so it's, it, it's gonna create something
called a system design rule and then also
a hook which uh which we can watch.
And then with the power there's an MCP.
Jason. So this is, this is the MCP configuration.
So Figma has an MCP server
and so
you can add one or more MCPs
within, within a power,
but working with FIGMA, the FGM, they have
one MCP.
So
now what I'm gonna go ahead and do is I'm actually
gonna say.
Try power.
And see what happens.
So as you can see, it, it, it activated the figma
power. And tells
you what you can do with the figma power.
And the first thing it it's doing, is doing, it's
doing this thing called, it's saying it needs to create
design system rules.
Now what create design system rules is a tool
in the MCP for Figma, but
if you were to just download the the Figma MCP
and
start working with it,
it wouldn't automatically get invoked.
In fact, you like there's documentation
embedded in some Figma link which says
like copy this prompt, paste it in, and generate
this file.
What this file does is actually gives the agent
really good context on like
how to, uh, it gives Figma and
the agent
really good context about what the specific
project set up,
uh, what, what the specific project has in
terms of a design system.
So, uh,
this should generate shortly.
But it'll have things like what, what is the,
the CSS styling, what's the
like design tokens like the what's the, what are, what are layout
rules. Um, so colors,
right, these are all things that Figma finds
very useful and the agent also finds very
useful when, when
it generates code.
Now, it's, so it created the steering
file and it it it's got the steering file with this
inclusion mode as always.
So what this means is now I have the steering file
included right here.
That every time the agent runs, it will use this
file as context because Figma really thinks that this
is an important file for the agent to have
access to. And
second, it created something called, uh,
this is slightly more contextual
to like an audience that's familiar
with Figma,
but it created a hook called Figma
component code connect.
Now what that does is that Figma has this concept
of components.
In your UI you have conceptual components, and you can
really map the two together.
So,
what, the way this hook runs is that it says that on
every, it should, it should be in every file
create. It'll basically
map try and map the component to
the Figma
version of the component.
So that's really what you can get with this power. So right
at the box, you get an onboarding experience that's fully guided,
that isn't just, OK, go install an MCP server
from the docks and figure out how to work with it.
And as a developer, there's nothing more important than
staying in the flow.
Right, so
All right, so it's saying, OK, great, my Sigma power
is now up and ready to use.
And it's giving me some examples again, so this is,
this is all very useful because it
gives you, it's almost like documentation that you'd have to follow
but without leaving your editor.
Now, if I were to go to Figma, Figma has this feature
called Dev mode right here,
which allows me to select a component.
And I can just copy this example prompt.
That says implement this design from Figma.
And then I go in here
Um, and I'm gonna just go ahead and paste that.
And let's see what the agent does.
Hopefully this works.
Yep, so it's trying to get this
tool from Figma.
I'm just gonna go ahead and auto approve.
The tools would never ask me for permission
again. Um.
OK, great.
OK, so now it's connected to the Figma I fetched that frame
and what you can see it says I've found this
topic. Let me convert this design
to match your project CSS approach. So it's taking
like the Figma context
and it's got context because it includes
that design context file at the beginning.
It is going to say, oh wow, like it's
now I can understand what you've got in your
project and what Figma has,
and it's now gonna go ahead and
create a new enhanced topic
card component.
Let's see how it does.
So the interesting, the funny thing here is like I've,
I did this like 2 times before the demo
and both times the results were slightly different
and that is just the nature of working with
uh AI systems right now,
uh, but they were close enough so I'm hoping
this is this this version is also
gonna be um pretty good.
So this is the other cool thing we've launched with Quiro
this in the last couple of months.
When we first launched Quiro, the agent would
have a lot more errors in the
actual interface, and it requires some back and
forth to fix them.
But we launched diagnostics tool support
which actually can look at find like linting lint
issues, linting errors,
and we launched support for like dev server so it can
read like compile time errors and, and the agent
just like auto recovers itself
so it's, it's, I was able to do
most all my demos this, this reinvent uh
this is my 4th session
without the agent really making
mistakes which has been super cool.
And now I'm gonna jinx myself for sure.
While this is happening, let me just show you how
I can, how easy it is to create a power.
So I have this power that I've built,
um,
I, I really like so Chrome has a devtools
server that what what it lets you do
is it it it actually will run Chrome
and be able to do things like click on components
test for responsiveness.
Check, like, make hover effects, uh,
it can do a lot,
um, so I've set up this, uh, Chrome
Dev Tools power and,
uh, it's essentially got two files. It's got a
power. MD file.
With like instructions for what to do
and an MCPJS and an MCPJN file.
Now, for me to add this to Quiro, it's gonna
be um
super easy. I would just go into
Quiro here
in the cust say add custom power.
Import a power from a folder.
Uh.
And there, now I have a Chrome Dev
Tools UI testing power available to me as
well. OK, so it implemented
something. Let's see how it did what it did.
All right.
Oh, not bad.
It's pretty good.
And let's, let's actually now go ahead and see if like
I can invoke the Chrome Dev Tools power,
OK, uh, now
run Chrome Dev Tools to make sure.
Everything is OK.
OK, so it's running a background power.
And let's see if it
OK, great.
Oh, did I have my MCP
on? Oh, I'm,
I cheated a little bit. I unfortunately had
not disabled the
the actual MCP server, but that's
fine, um.
So what, what this is gonna do now is that you see how it
opened its own instance and now check out what it's
gonna do.
It's gonna see, so Dev serve is running
now. There's a, the new design is rendering great.
Let me check the console for any errors. So look
at the runtime, look at the actual console runtime,
see if the errors. OK, no errors. Now let me test the hover
effects. And
so it's gonna allow actually like hover on the UI
component I believe the UI component has some hover states
to see if the hover works.
And now it's doing OK, how is this gonna work on a mobile
device? It's gonna resize the,
the, the page.
And yeah, so this, so I think you, you, you
get the gist of it. So the, the powers really give
you the ability, the agent ability like a
toolkit abilities, a Swiss Army knife of abilities
without overwhelming it with context, and
I, I kind of walked you through the Figma use case.
I'm gonna, uh,
ask Harry to come on and, and, uh,
talk about Postman. Awesome.
Uh, where I'm at here.
Hi everybody. My name's uh Harry Mauer. I'm the Field
CTO of Postman, and in my role, I
help our largest customers improve their
overall software development process.
Um,
how many of you familiar with Postman? How many of you use
Postman? Yeah, there you go.
So for those that haven't, um, Postman
is the most widely used tool to
test and design and to manage your APIs.
We're used by over 40 million developers.
Over 500,000 organizations have adopted
us, and we've become one of those,
uh, indispensable tools in the developer
toolkit, sort of like,
you know, Git and VS code, strong coffee,
and, uh, noise canceling headphones, right?
We're part of the, the tool chest that every
developer
typically uses.
Um, for those that aren't familiar with me, I
had a long history in developer tools.
Um, I spent a long time at Microsoft in Developer Tools.
I ran, uh,
Dev Tools for Red Hat for a long time. I
actually worked on Dev Tools at AWS,
and now I'm here at Postman, and I've never been more
excited about software development. I
feel like my entire
20+ year career has led to this
point where my code is finally
able to write my code, right? And it's just
awesome how much you can get done
in just a short amount of time with these tools, but.
For as
powerful as they are, uh, they still need
a lot of guidance, right? So as Nikil was saying, they're
very much generous, and they need a lot
of guidance and knowledge
to help them do the job in the way that you want them to do it,
right? So you gotta tell them what kind of framework
to use and what kind of language to use, and
importantly for Postman, which APIs
you want to use to build in your
application. Um, and this
is where we see Postman continuing to
play an indispensable role, right?
As I mentioned, millions of developers use
Postman to collaborate and build their
APIs and test them and manage them. And
increasingly those developers are being joined
by countless numbers of agents,
right? So agents now are wanting
to do the same thing that developers did.
They want to
test their APIs, they want to,
uh, share the APIs, and they want to do
that not only with other developers, but with other
agents as well.
And today we enable that
through our Postman MCP server. So
there's an MCP server out there today that you can use
within whichever coding agent
or assistant that supports MCP that
you wanna use,
but there's some limitations to it, and this is
why we're so excited to be partnering with the Quiro
team, right?
You know, for instance, we want to provide a
lot of capabilities to those MCP
servers,
so we have over 100 tools, but most of
them really can't deal with that many tools, right?
So we have a slimmed down version which only has 40
tools, which can also sometimes
overwhelm them, right? So one of the things we're really
excited about in here is the ability for that to automatically
load after we
install uh the, the MCP
server, right?
And the other thing that
we usually stumble upon is when someone
goes to use our MCP server,
we're relying on them to actually write
the
system prompts to make it more effective, right?
And so now with Kira, we have these steering files, and
we can package all this up into a power
that makes our MCP server much
more powerful for the agent to
use. And so
rather than me talking about it, I wanna give you a quick demo.
Uh, I am not as fearless as Nikhil, so
I recorded mine. Um, let's see if we can
get the video going.
So I've got a, uh, sample application. It's
a personal finance application. It's interesting,
me and Tyler both started working on the same thing.
Um,
it's pretty robust. It's got a
lot of the same things that you would expect to have
in a large enterprise scale application. It's
got a query PI. It's got an SDK,
it's got a CLI.
And I use Postman to help
manage all of the different versions
and share those APIs with
my team.
So in my pipelines, I automatically generate
a collection and a spec for each
version,
and I do that as part of my pipeline
process. But when I want
to build an API that I can collaborate on,
one that's still in development,
I also want to create a collection and be able to share
that with my other development teams.
So through the new Quiro Power,
um, I can do that with, right with inside my
IDE. Here's a sample prompt I put
together. I'm asking Kira to
create a collection based
off an endpoint within my
API for just reporting.
And one of the things that we tell in the steering file is
we tell Kira to keep
a Postman.json file
for all of the metadata about the
workspace and the collection and the user
information that we use,
and we build upon that as we go because it's
gonna help some of our more advanced features
like the hooks work later on.
So as
Kira goes through the process here.
It's going to use my API key
to collect, to connect to Postman.
It's going to read my code,
understand the endpoints that I need to make,
and then it automatically creates this collection
inside of my workspace
that now I can share with my team,
right? So it's got everything it needs here.
And you should see that here. So there, there's my
new uh endpoint in development.
This is pretty cool, but if someone went to go to use this,
it wouldn't really work. It would tell them what the input was
supposed to look like, but there's no real way to test
this. And so one of the cool features inside of Postman
is the ability
to create mock servers and environments
for APIs that aren't quite finished yet,
right? So I can mock out this environment.
I can share that with the team who needs it downstream
while I'm continuing to develop the implementation.
And so I can do that now inside directly
inside a hero instead of having to do that inside a Postman.
I don't ever have to leave
my IDE, so.
Another prompt I asked, I tell Kira, hey, let's
take that collection you just built, the one you just saved
inside of that JSON file, and now let's build
a mock environment and server
for that,
so that we can test these directly, or we can
test these without the implementation being completed.
So it's gonna go through the process here of doing that.
And again, as it does this, it
keeps adding to that metadata, and the reason it can
do that is because we told it to do that in the steering
file, right?
If I had to rely on the end user to
do that, you, I don't, I couldn't rely on you
all to do that, right?
So we automatically package that up for you to do that.
Uh, so the mock server was automatically
created. And
again, this, the only thing I had to tell Kierra to
do was look at my code, right? I didn't have
to write a spec. I didn't have to do anything like that. I said,
investigate, look at my code, create this collection.
Once you create the collection,
now you know everything about that,
go create this virtual environment inside of Postman.
which has a mock server in it, and all the environment variables
that I need. And now I can actually go
and test this and get, oh, and get test data
back to be able to run that collection, right?
Um, and as I said, this is really great because, you know, now
I don't have to, the other team, if I'm a downstream
team, I don't have to wait on me to
finish it,
and I can also just start to test
that right here
inside Akira, so I wanna make sure it works for the other team.
Now why this is cool and why I wanted to show this is.
This is a standard test that we're gonna run,
not only just to validate the collection work and
the mock environment worked,
but it's also gonna be called every
time I make a change to the source
code, because I automatically packaged a
Quiro hook
inside of it. So one of the things that you would do as you're
developing your APIs, you want to go back and test it and make sure
everything works.
So now automatically when I change the source
code and save it,
Kiiro knows that because there's a hook inside of there, and it's
going to run that same
collection in that mock environment that we created
and make sure everything still works, right? So now we've
got this closed loop system.
So this is one small example. Like I said, we have
over 100 tools inside of our MCP server.
You know, you can do everything from creating collections and workspaces
and sharing them and also generating other code.
So we're really interested
and excited to see what y'all are gonna do with it. It's
available today. You can go install it from the
Quiro marketplace, and we also have a
Discord server. We'd love to get your feedback.
Uh, so if you could take the time to join, we'd
love to hear it, and, uh, you know, hopefully you'll
get a lot of value out of it. So thank you.
Tyler.
Let's see your personal finance app.
Thanks, Harry.
Cool. Hi
everyone. I'm
Tyler and I'm, uh, Deverel at
Superbase,
and today I'm gonna talk to you about
Superbase
and the Koower that we're launching.
For those who don't know what Superbeast is,
Superbeast
is a back-end platform
loved by many developers
across the world.
We have 5 million
developers shipping over
90,000 databases
every single day.
And we have shipped in total
60 million databases.
Today Earlier
this year,
we shipped our MCP server.
The Superbase MCP server
includes numerous tools
for building applications on
top of Superbase.
You can do things like
list out tables.
Manage your database migrations.
Manage your storage bucket,
really anything that you can do
within the Superbase platform.
This MC MCP server
forms the backbone of our QO
power. And
I am happy
to announce.
The QO power for Superbass.
We are announcing two QO powers from
Superbase.
1. To work with your
local Superbase database.
And another
to work with a hosted Subabase database.
So that you can start locally.
And deploy your Superbase database
to your cloud.
It uses a Superbase MCP
and the Superbase CLI
to build,
manage,
debug,
and scale application
with the help
from an LLM.
Not just having access to these tools,
but the superbase KO powers.
Understands the best practices.
of how to use
Superbase
and how to use Eposcus database.
So you don't have to be a database expert.
In order to get building
on a Poscu database.
Now let's see it in action.
It's all good.
So I'm gonna start
With a plain
beat up. I'm
gonna go ahead
and install the superbase
local kilo kilopower.
I'm gonna hit install
and hit try power,
and off we go.
We're going to start up by the.
Onboarding flow,
and it's going to check things like
whether I have docker running,
whether I have the Super BCLI installed.
And whether I have initialized
the Superbase project
uh within the working directory.
Now, I hadn't initialized Superbeast in
here, so it went ahead and initialized
Subabeast for me.
And then now it's fetching the Superbase
credentials
and creating an environment
bearable environment file
for me within this project directory.
Now, once all the initial setup is done, we
are going to jump into building some
tables.
So,
I'm also gonna work on a personal
financing, personal banking app.
So I'm telling Keo here
to create all the tables
that you need in order to build a
personal banking app.
And Keo is able to
understand all the best practices
to build tables,
best security practices when it
comes to Superbase,
and incorporate all that
in here.
So it has created the tables,
it has created all the necessary security
safeguards.
To make sure we create a nice
and safe
banking app.
Now one of the key
powers
that we're shipping
is this
security check.
It's part of a Sub core feature,
and what it allows you to do is it.
It's able to take in all the best
security practices and make sure all the tables
and various configurations are following
those security best practices.
I'm gonna go ahead and run it
And it actually found something, some
problems.
So Ko was able to quickly fix that
up. By running
another SQL
segment. Now,
another favorite thing
about Superbase, another favorite thing
of mine
about Subabase,
is that it can generate type script types
that matches
your table schema.
And Keo's doing that for me,
without me having to tell it to generate
all these type,
TypeScript types.
It's able to understand
that we're working in a TypeScript environment.
And Subabase has this TypeScript
generation feature.
And we should probably generate some type script types.
And
there you go. Here it has created
the TypeScript types and now installing the Superbase
JavaScript client library.
So generating all these TypeScript types,
installing the Superbase client libraries,
these are standard practices that we follow.
And
he was able to do that
um without
me having to interfere
with any of the prompts.
It understands all these best, best practices,
uh, that it needs to do in order to get
started with a super-based project.
Now, finally, once all the tables are created,
all the configuration is set,
Keo's generating all the
database migrations.
And after a while,
let's check out the migration file that I created.
So you can see,
QO has created
a nice account stable for us
with all the comms that you would need
for a personal banking apps,
like user ID,
account type,
balance, currencies,
It also generated other tables too, like
budgets,
categories,
transactions.
All the tables that you would expect in a
personal banking app.
And then you can view that
within the Superbase dashboard.
You can see the transaction tables,
budgets tables,
all being associated
to the Aha user ID table.
So it has taken all the best practices
that Superbase offers.
And put it all together.
Now let's come back to QO.
And keep going
So it's now
generating some front-end code
to connect to our Superbase database.
This is a TypeScript type that I mentioned
earlier. And
as, as you can see, we have all the
matching typescript type that matches the table
schema. Now, let's
go ahead and create a new chat session.
And work on the UI.
So the prompt here that I'm giving it is basically
saying, hey,
I have these tables in my Superbase project.
Please create a UI that matches
what I have in the tables.
This is one of the neat tricks that I like
to work on, uh, neat. This is
one of the neat tricks that I like
to use when building apps using Superbase and
large language models. I like to start
from the tables.
And then once I'm done with the tables,
I have it generate the UI
because having a nice airtight table
structure is
very important.
And once all the tables in place,
LLMs are generally
really good at understanding what's going on
and figuring out the best UI
that goes with those tables.
So Ko is analyzing all the schema
that we generated.
And it's generating all these UI code
to display.
What we saw in the database
on the front end code.
And just like that,
We have
some nice set of proto code.
Let's run the local dev server.
And check it out.
So
The UA looks good, it looks
like a personal banking app,
but we don't see any data, right? Well, that's
because we just created the tables, but we haven't
inserted any data into it.
Obviously.
So, Let's go back
and ask Keo to add some dummy data into the database.
And Keo, again,
is able to
figure out
how to insert dummy data into Superbase, what
the best practice is.
And it's running
some SQL command
to insert.
Some dummy data into all the tables that
we created earlier.
And after inserting all these data
in 4 different tables,
It double checked, double checks
that all the data has been inserted.
And then I've asked you to
create a local
seed file to keep all these dummy data.
Persisted within this project.
Looks great.
Let's go ahead and check it out.
Now, Within the superbase
stable, we had those dummy data,
but it looked like.
We haven't signed into the app yet.
So, I'm asking Kyo to add authentication
to the app.
And Keel's able to
figure out.
The structure of the Superbase project,
the fact that,
um, obviously the passwords are encrypted,
so you wouldn't be able to insert just 123456
into the passwords column,
you need to properly
encrypt or hash the passwords.
It's able to figure out how Superbase
does it. And
Able to do that.
It's able to self-correct it.
So on the first shot,
we missed it,
but I've gone ahead and uh
asked you to.
Make some fixes
And
It's on its own, was able
to figure out
that, OK, the Superbase local
dev server needs to relaunch.
So without me telling it,
he was stopping the Superbase dev server,
relaunching it,
loading in all the see data
that we created again,
and resetting the scene
so that the proper authenticated user
is created
within the database.
And so far,
I have done minimal steering.
It's all the Keog's steering file
that's doing all the heavy lifting.
And with some edits from Ko.
We are able to sign into the app,
and as you can see,
you can view all the dummy data that
Qo created
in this nicely authenticated, proper
personal banking app.
So that was QO Power
from Superbase.
Again, we have the local version and hosted version.
And I hope you like
I hope you liked what you saw, see, and I
cannot wait to see what you build with it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you again Harry and Tyler. That was
really great. Uh, we really appreciate both of, both
of you coming here and talking about
the powers and, and this both powers
are super useful. I've been using both of them for,
for my own application development,
so I, I, I've, I've really benefited
from actually learning a lot about Postman and
Super Bass
over this last month.
Cool. So what's next? There's a lot of, uh,
a lot of questions,
uh, I think available in the CLI
we wanna actually make we have a hero CLI
if you don't know,
uh, we also wanna make it available more broadly.
Uh, more use cases, more partners, we've, we
have a, uh,
on our website
we have a way for you to submit, uh, a
form and actually send us powers,
and we, we're reviewing them
weekly and if we find interesting ones
we can curate them.
You can do it as an individual as well, by the way. It doesn't
have to be your organization.
If you have uh a specific use case that
you wanna highlight
and it and we're we're
it meets our bar for adding
him on we we're happy to do it.
Um,
I think organizational use use cases are gonna
be a big one. So being able to govern like powers
around what powers teams can install
is gonna be, uh, another feature that
we add,
and I think our, our goal here is really for Quiro.
The, the keyro agent has powers,
and over time, like, uh, a key agent
should be able to discover powers and say, hey,
you're trying to do this. I know there's a power to do to
solve this problem
without the user actually having to like
explicitly go and say anything.
Yeah, so, as I, as we said, you can go ahead and start using
it right away on Quiro, and thank you so much again
everyone for taking your time. I appreciate
everyone joining at 4, you know, at 4 p.m.,
and, uh, I'm happy to take, uh,
questions if you have questions. Happy to kind of
if you come up and we can,
uh, take
take questions. Thanks again.